and if we look back to Indian times when
you know people lived in their Native
Americans right and they lived in their
whatever is called their tribe right
people have sex with
everyone and the paternity was not a an
issue that was also a very Native
Americans there's a lot of there's a lot
of different tribes in Native Americans
so I'm asking like which ones well
because like usually when I hear this
stuff it's an exception it's not the
rule that was like widespread amongst us
I'm saying it says here that
um descendants in the communities in
North America Quebec Michigan Kansas
Oklahoma all around the center the 17th
century
um
which is right before it was colonized
which makes sense yeah so you know those
were people that belonged to a clan that
basically took care of their children
like everyone took care of everyone's
children but I'm asking like how did it
work with the paternity like like you
said everyone was sleeping with everyone
yeah but we lived we all live here we
all take care of the kids no I'm not
talking about that I'm saying like how
did it work like sexually like everyone
was sleeping with everyone is that what
you're saying so one woman was having
six different guys with uh babies
she could have
okay it just it doesn't this just
doesn't make sense with the data because
again like only for 40 of men have
reproduced historically so it seems like
it would have been one minute like the
powerful men with multiple women but if
I have sex with several different men
and I don't know who the father is yeah
it doesn't matter that he couldn't
reproduce no what matters is that well
now we're talking about decision making
and what matters is the fact that you're
just sleeping around
clearly unprotectedly to the point where
you don't know who the dad is whether it
be two men or one man I mean two men or
more we were talking about historically
well I'm just saying historically and
the thing is what ends up happening is
we try to take something that has
happened in one spot right which the
tribes and if we go back back to the
17th century there was two main groups
of Native Americans or Native Americans
at that time right one of them
predominantly was the Moore's American
and then the other one I don't know the
name of that but the Moore's American
actually made up majority of America
before the colonization right to my
knowledge now that I can tell you in
Moore's American being that they were
probably the majority uh most powerful
people in America they did not abide by
those rules now the other different
Native Americans that had different
tribes and different cultures which
could range right it could be a tribe it
could be 20 people it could be 100
people it could be 2 000 people right
now we're trying to argue with rules of
their own rules okay but then what ends
up happening is that's not
the majority of the world right it
doesn't matter if we want to go back to
Asian Africa right or we want to go to
Europe or we want to go to Asia India
even India first and foremost
um one of the Hindu is the longest
um most current culture in you know to
the man's knowledge right so with that
being said they don't even believe in
that right in the in the Hindu religion
they don't believe in women sleeping
with multiple men and actually I mean
they really don't believe in mentally
but when multiple women either
technically it is an equality thing over
there but and and in my personal opinion
I think that that is the best choice
right
which is kind of going off on the
tangent but I do think that men should
not sleep with as many women as they as
we get praised to right only because if
you get really good at it
why would you stop
you know what I'm saying and then
especially if I'm that guy now it makes
no sense to stop but for a women's from
a woman's perspective you've got to pay
to play so if you are not paying okay if
you're not covering these bills if
you're not protecting if you're not
doing these things you need to be what
is that person that will be doing those
Mo those are called survival skills men
are providing survival skills for women
and then women are thinking that they
can just sleep out and you know
spontaneously frivolously recklessly
what women are these well I mean there's
women that saying that body count
doesn't matter and it does I just think
it's the quality of women that you're
coming around because let me ask you a
question
you're a man
right to me I don't care how many women
and to me I think it's like a being
selfish and jealous when um if I ask a
man how many women have you slept with
he said a hundred and I'm like oh my God
worry about this I don't have to worry
about that because now it's you're with
me
now if I'm insecure and I think that
those other hundred women are even
better than me or we're doing or
whatever it is whatever the reason is so
if you have a woman and she's great she
you do not have to pay her bills okay
because she has her own right
she doesn't need you to protect her
because she can take care of herself but
you know she wants you as a man so of
course if you see something you'll be
like oh I got you whatever and she
provides 90 of the things that you want
90 but that 10 is the body count
that is bothering you right that that
body conquered so high is it it doesn't
matter whatever number give me a number
what number what number would put you
off what number would the number yeah
Rico could tell the number what number
is too high for you yeah what number
a number that's too high for me is
is 45 what age is she because that does
play a big part it doesn't matter
because a 19 year old 25 26 25 27 feet
she's 25 yeah 25 oh God the numbers are
going to be lower uh she's 25. so what
do you typically date 25 I say she has
to have less than 10.
mathematically the way I look at it is
she lost her virginity at 17 17 to 25
that's what eight years that gives her
about one and a third one and a half a
year that's fair to me okay so that
means that that means that and if she's
25 see this is the thing like when we
really start to break down body count if
a woman tells me she's 25 right and
she's been in two relationships and each
relationship lasted 18 months right so
now we got 36 months right which is
three years okay so now we have 25 minus
three years is 22 right so you're
telling me really and let's say she lost
her virginity at 17. so 17 to 25 is what
eight minus three so in five years you
tell me you have 20 men that you slept
with okay yeah so she said 20. we'll go
with that number I'm going to say 20.
even if you say 20. but I'm gonna say
something real quick but let me say but
like even if you say 20 then this is
what happens Lonnie as a man I'm
starting to think you say 20. that means
in five years that you were available
right outside of two men so now we got
18 men that you slept within a five in a
five year period how many minutes that a
month
so you're almost damned you're probably
supposed to damn near a man it doesn't
matter
I'm older than both of you guys and to
me if we're in a relationship and I have
to sit here and do all this calculating
just so we can discuss body count when
we could be making money when we could
be building something you think I'm
gonna waste my time to do in five years
you wear nothing so your body count is
if you think I'm gonna waste my time
wasting your time every time you decide
to sleep with somebody and not build
with them I wasted my time being in a
relationship with you because your ass
is smart enough
let's go back to that let's go back to
the question let's go back to the
question so you have the you have the
ten percent right you have the 10 which
is the body count of 20 guys so you're
going I'm saying
she gives you everything you want that
90 is everything you want in a person
but she slept with 20 men
right at age 25.
would you
because there's too much for you right
yo you can't do it I'm not doing that
it's wow to me bro
because y'all been in a relationship 35
I mean realistically I know what let's
say 25 I was I wasn't close to 20 but I
was at least around like double like
let's say 40. right so like you said
with half their amount that's crazy to
me absolutely not there's no way in
God's green earth that I'm going to
expand myself for a woman that slept
with this with even half of the amount
of uh men that I slept with women is it
doesn't make sense to me it doesn't make
sense to you but the question was not
that a woman she provides you with 90 of
the things that you need in a
relationship so she has I think you said
things like paying your own her own
ability do you care about that I'm
assuming most guys don't I mean I that's
what he wrote up I I would I do care
about it right so like if a woman is
holding her own and she's
self-sufficient I find that I find that
very attractive okay but now hour is
different and we're talking about what
is your bills though because paying your
own bills and it's only two thousand
dollars a month you live in this 600
square foot studio and it's 900 a month
and then all the rest about about 70
hundred so you tell them you pay all
your bills and it's only two thousand
dollars a month that's not impressive to
me but if you pay all your own bills and
it's five thousand dollars a month now
we're talking about okay okay okay so so
women out I can make some exceptions but
if but if a woman typically is paying
her own bills and let's just give it a a
number for them okay for the sake yeah
we'll say five thousand a month yeah you
got to be doing something good right if
you're paying five thousand a month
that's 60 000 a month I mean 60 000 a
year in bills I'm assuming that you're
making six figures okay okay so now
if we run with that I'm like okay cool
this is a six-figure woman this is
probably why her body count is high
right she doesn't have the time to
really invest in a relationship I
probably would not even indulge into a
relationship more so it'd be a fun thing
and I'd probably be 20 number 21.
it's been
three percent of the stuff you want
because it's impossible right that's
possible I don't even know what do you
mean I mean she better but she's just
giving a hypothetical so it's not
realistic it is
a question body count you be you'd be
out 20. as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible